I'm a very warm welcome indeed to this
latest edition of talking Germany the
show where we do just that to my guest
today is a woman who is a writer a
singer and a photographer in fact a
communicator and one of the main things
she communicates about is her truly
remarkable life so let's meet her in
person Stefan eat layer or Congo
Stephanie thank you very very much for
joining us today thank you german thing
great to have him here now just to give
you some clues about Stephanie's
biography let me tell you that she's
lived in what might be called a cultural
triangle made up of the former East
Germany the southern African country of
Namibia and present-day reunified
Germany it's a story of hope but also of
despair of great charity and shocking
prejudice and much else besides you're
not inc yeah yeah I must have got
something right Stephanie what I would
like to begin with and I didn't it I
didn't mention it in my introduction
there deliberately is I want to begin
with where you began with the kissing
ger massacre I think it's very important
that you tell us that story in your own
words yes so my parents they were future
fighter and they were fighters against
this roses and apartheid system of South
African and both of them they wear em in
a in the camp so a training training
camp so my father was a soldier and my
mom she was a nurse she was becoming a
nurse and both of them they felt in love
and my dad for so he was so laughs with
my mom and and and she receive us always
coming to say oh you're so lovely and
she's a no go red so it was always like
this and so this young and these young
people they felt one day they fell in
love and my mom has to leave the scams
as trainee campers explain where the
camp was located very important yes it
wasn't a thousand part of Angola because
Angola was one of the countries who
helped Namibia further and further and
dependents okay and your mum and your
dad were both originally from Namibia
I'm the media there
angolan but they were original from
Namibia so and when they felt a laugh my
mom becomes pregnant with me and she
have to leave this camp and she went two
days before the big masaq of kasinga
moussaka haven't she she came there and
so she was in this camp and she only
slept these two days and and when she
woke up on the force was on the force of
May she heard a lot of bombs and people
were crying and she didn't know where to
go and and they said all goes as well
the South Africans who would launch the
attack the South African military yes it
was it's us African people who who made
this attack on these people because it
was African they say they are saying
that it is they saw it it is a cam from
and from Z so Apple Apple organizations
of the south west african PS the
independence movement of course ma'am
and this is is but they said that was
dispensed was came from this rapper but
it wasn't goes my bootcamp it was it
came for women for people who are
injured for old people and and it was
and there were only civil person people
who were there okay so there is a bit of
a dispute about that but what you're
telling us there's no knows about what
that whatsoever there were a lot of
civilians there only one of them was
your mother she was pregnant with you
yes and she was struck by bullet fire
yes and she when she was attacked by
them and she was very very very hardly
injured so so hardly that the M that she
was one of the first people who could
leave this camp so she came to Germany
to eastern part of germany to do Julia
because this country will decided to
help people to help Namibia for the
independence okay we'll pick up on that
story they do it where where where she
went next your mother with you yeah
unborn about stage but just didn't as I
understand it you have said and this is
I find truly remarkable that when you
talk about the casino massacre you
obviously what you were you know your
mother was pregnant with you so you
weren't actually
air as a born child but you say you are
still haunted by images from the
massacre although you couldn't actually
see what was going on hey so I it's I
don't know how it is M&M I don't know
how it is like this but it's like this
so I see pictures FC people are crying
and screaming and them so because of
this day it was I don't know how it is
what it is like this so over 800 people
were killed on this day and a lot of
more than sounds injured so I maybe it's
I became it for my mom because maybe it
was her nightmares later I don't know
but it's it's it's like this so I don't
know how it came so yeah but it's the
truth okay thank you
there's one fact I need to get to get
from you Stephanie you said 800 people
civilians were killed in the casino
massacre was that including children or
was there was that 800 adults and then
children it's it's inside the children I
insects so they're included in that no
because they were quite a lot of
children and one of the survivors as we
have learnt was your mother she was
brought then to East Berlin to East
Germany and that's where you grew up
what was your first memory that's East
Berlin and my first memory is the garden
where I was growing up yeah and because
um it's such such a beautiful handmade
boot and built God for my for my father
for my stepfather okay and a host father
so yeah yeah okay and and so these are
one of my first memories I've got in the
garden ok that's all whistling that is
obviously a very very happy memory
indeed yes before that something else
actually happened you you were in East
Berlin for a very a relatively short
period of time then when I think you
were about 14 months old you and your
mother had to go back to Namibia what
happened there exactly ok so the M so
the government decided that all the
people who are feeling better who
injured who were injured has to go back
to to namibia 2 to be fighters for the
independence and and so my mom was one
of these and so for me it wasn't going
back because I never been there because
i was born in berlin and but i have to
go with her and we went back to him to a
Namibia where the war wasn't over yet
the problems were the same so I am I
went there and my mom she was so she was
traveling with her own problems or own
medical problems so she couldn't even
took care of myself and I become very
very ill during the time and I couldn't
ever some more than one year old but I
couldn't walk I couldn't talk I couldn't
do anything I had a lot of problems and
so my mom this was because of the these
were because of the injured injuries to
your mother in the massacre because I'm
doing
whenever I was born there was a very
problems I was mmm when I was born I had
a lot of problems because it couldn't
get any air during the time and I had
ever I came I was born was a Hemi
parties it's um it's a half the after of
your body isn't very proper cannot work
very proper so um so all of these
problems ever Swami's ever small I was
slow I was all my old man my developing
was worried okay so that was you you
were in you you were taken back to
Namibia in the condition that you're
explaining yes and your your foster
family your host family in East Berlin
they said we're not gonna go with that
they actually fought against this they
fought for you to come back and they
went to very high places they only send
a bit of influence tell us of course so
they they went to all the people to all
the ministers and all the people in
every section they could go and they
asked for an tell the story and they
wrote to Namibia even to the swapo
people and all the institutions they
could go to and told them my story and
all of them they said no we cannot do
anything she has to go back he has to
stay there she can't go back and so so
it was really it was this really
struggling time and even now when I read
these letters they wrote and all these
communication and sheets who are even
now they are already there so and it was
really hard for them so and and and
there was some one situation and one of
my mom because I've got four moms can
you imagine this I've got four months
yes that's me I have just one and so one
of my mom's she um she met she met Mago
tonica's or Irish Annika the leader of
East Germany yes and because my mom she
choosin stewardess um and she she she
met her on during a fly in Africa and so
she took
talk to each other and my mom she it was
eastern time and she she when during
that time they met everyone in the
airplane their their own food and so she
made the food for magnet Annika and put
some small eggs and all these things
from Germany when how they celebrate
ramen and she put it on a plate to give
it to her and mallow tonic was so
touched and I said who are you where are
you what does his story and my mom she
told her the story of my life and and so
and during that time I got honey covers
of was a minister and so even for use
and all this stuff and so she was and
she said okay I would do some ever tried
to help you and that's what she said she
don't you broke she had a role in you
coming back I mean it was the courage of
your mum as you're saying it was a
mugger hanukkah also had a role of class
xi and UK you came to live in East
Berlin you've talked about the Adil
exceed in the garden the beautiful
garden in your foster family and I know
that you have gone on record as saying
your childhood was happy normal almost
idyllic in the former East Germany and
childhood an adult life are very
different but a lot of people our
viewers will be surprised perhaps with
that because when they think of East
Germany pop probably the the word that
comes to mind is dictatorship yes you're
sitting here and saying well it was a it
was a happy time I was grown up in a in
a country where where there was no war I
was I could go to school I was a had a
family where I am where was um I'm cat
and so um so this is that was the state
I was living that's important in for a
child is actually for a child who's been
what you had been now I was 11 years old
when Z and when the war was breaking
poke around and Sean and Judy is a place
where so all the stuff I had enough to
eat after enough to drink and for me it
wasn't important to travel to to my yoga
or to the Baltic Sea to make holiday you
know so as a child so I played on the
beach like every child so for me it
wasn't a different story and my power
told me you could be purple it doesn't
matter we would love you so I didn't had
any ball so important yes it was okay
okay we'll talk about all of this
identity German asst East German listen
just a second will pick up on some of
that again Stefan and I know it's not
your side of the story but do you
understand why people become foster
parents where they do it yes and i think
they because I want to help children who
they want to give children who don't
have so much chances and a place where
they can grown up Reza can stay for wire
and a good condition do you understand
the risks that they take the emotional
risks they take by bonding with the
children because you've been in that
situation yourself you know how it's
precarious of course it is because I'm
so even in my situation the my parents I
didn't know how how long I can stay in
their family and it was a real problem
for them as well even for me because
nobody's every time the government could
say okay she has to go back to Namibia
so it's over now and so and and so you
you're close to the stride and you you
you don't know how long and takes us
there did you talk to them about that at
the time or have you talked to them
openly about those emotions since cuz
they're very complex emotions of course
I never had so much fear my fear was
ever lose his family but ever wasn't
unable I was unable to talk about it so
I was since it was so inside myself and
I said okay if I talk about it so I get
some problems and they and ever so
fearful so I did not talked about about
anybody about my my love you mmm and you
still view them as your family now
really is your family family know what
about you what about your mother i know
she has in the meantime passed away and
i think i don't know if it's the right
word to use but i think you you two had
become a little bit estranged you and
your mother do do you did you miss her
do you miss her hmm so it's really very
complicated the situation was my mom
so she um she is I know the struggling
she went through and I know she made
good decisions for myself and I could
grow up in this way I'm living now and
and and I love her for the father for
her situation and what she's been
through and how she helped me but for
our relationship it was really every
time it was very complicated and and I
was used to have him to have three
mothers who took care so oddly so so
wonderful for me and and I know it I I
realized how wonderful it is to have to
have mothers who take care of you and
who loves you unconditionally and i
dinnae then i get to know my real mom
and there were so many problems and i
couldn't bring it together because i
said her they don't they are not my real
parents but they laughed me and you are
my room mom and you you are treating me
like this it's like love against biology
almost it was always the skin fight
inside myself and even on the outside so
and by day but I laughs oh and then miss
her even a mr. because I miss a lot of
stories and miss I'm missing my past I'm
missing the place where I come from she
choose she's the only one who can give
me an answer but how was I am how was
what kind of feeling was when you when I
give you when you give me burst under
when I was born born and what was the
first saw when you saw me and and was
Emma how was about my when I was a baby
was a good baby or anything like this
you know so I've got so many questions
and she couldn't gave me the answer for
that that's why I was so sorry about
that she's not here and I can understand
that absolutely somewhere I read the
following i'm interested in your
relationship to namibia as well took the
you know to mother africa of you so well
in the form of namibia here somewhere I
read in one of the texts about you it
became clear to Stephanie after several
journeys to Namibia that she is a black
is that your identity now it is so so
I'm an ethyl methyl german girl lady
woman and so that's my den-tits it's my
story so um I'm black and even when i'm
going to Namibia I'm so the people know
when I'm talking when I'm walking they
know I'm not Namibian you know and so
I'm always between that the two
countries and so but it's okay it's not
and before it was always a problem
lesser my goodness out to the side I
have to decide if I'm wanna maybe a
normal German only texts that is the
lexus so it's both so fifty percent so
um hmm and what what I'd also like to
ask you because the things in Germany
can be very fit things in any culture
and society can be complicated as you
know and as I know but I'm wondering is
it is it do you I don't know if you can
answer this in any way but is do you
imagine that it's this that it's the
same thing being a black german woman as
it is more or less being a black English
one or a black French woman or maybe
even a black American woman or is there
something small something singular about
being a black german mmm the story of
blacks and Germany and it's as it sounds
like it's a really young history but
it's the lexus so the history of blacks
here and germany it's really very very
long that is an important point yes mmm
it seems like it's short but it's not
shot it's really long so there are a lot
of people who came showing the cert and
drink and this is this time long long
time to two hundred years or even longer
who came during the time to germany who
worked for for the former king and who
worked in the in the time where i'm
hitler was there and even before so the
they kept their there were a lot of
people
the black people here in Germany and and
for me it's M it's a bit but it's a bit
different because of this history we've
got in Germany it's different histories
ends than the history and America for
example and these people it's a smaller
group of black people here in Germany
then and maybe in England or in America
or even friends yeah but so that sets
may be different because they cannot
come together to to work together to
help each other but and and it looks
like they are only single biographies
here and but it's really it's not it's
really it's I think it's different but
the history and it's a long history of
black people here in Germany
is it a method is it a strategy laughing
about eight about racism it's a method
because i think it's an easier way to
bring people into a theme um but for me
it's important also important to to to
talk about later in a serious way about
it because you can laugh about it but
you have to bring the connection that
it's observe so if a racist comment is
made somewhere in your environment
somewhere in your immediate surroundings
you can laugh about it or you can you
can treat it humorously on on condition
that later you have a conversation with
these people and say hey you're off the
mark there so I try to so i am i am i'm
learning at the amendment process now
true so to find a way to deal with it
because normally you're sitting dancing
what did she said excuse me what for
what so and but so i try to find a
humorous way as well as a serious way to
to bring them the connection that
there's something wrong with it so and
i'm becoming better and it probably it's
probably important because a lot of
people who make racist comments aren't
necessarily full of hate just people who
don't they don't know any better they're
they're helpless people sorry officer
yeah so that's why i tried to bring it
under to think about it so no i in the
introduction to that report i said that
it is my / i'm all I'm asked about
Germany a lot because I'm a
correspondent here in and I often say
Germany is moving quite rapidly from
being a mono-ethnic society that I knew
20 years ago to being a multi-ethnic
society and I think that's the good news
from Germany at the same time there is a
lot of racism still as everywhere else
but some of it very specific to Germany
how bad would you say the situation is
in Germany it's it's bad so Evan said
nicely so it's a recession situation
here Germany is back like but like every
in every other country as well so um you
say there are no go areas
here in this city where you and I both
live yes I'm not happy about about what
can you tell us well I'm not saying I'm
not happy about the comment but I'm
happy that there are no go area so their
places I cannot go alone and then there
are places where I wouldn't stand on a
traffic jam and and wait for the Basso
and it Alexis so i wouldn't i don't use
a bath but normally or I wouldn't have a
there's a situation like this and where
I have to where people are working
beside me and said what are you doing
here excuse me you don't have to belong
to this place these places where you
wouldn't go are they in the eastern
former but what about they are they in
Eastern Berlin or Western Berlin because
you know what I'm getting at but it's an
important question we've got God and
then it's difficult for me to answer
because I don't want to bring nem nem
this is right this is wrong for sure
it's good I understood I think our
viewers that's why I don't want to give
him that's right it's difficult for me
to give you an one hundred percent
answer but I might in my opinion only in
my opinion is the most of these places
are the eastern part but if you are
looking around at the surrounding of
Berlin and even in the western side I
won't be there alone at the night as
well OMG afternoon or so but it's for my
my view of it it's like it's more decent
set of how do you explain that given
what you were saying about you were
saying earlier that you could have been
purple in the former East Berlin and
that would have been okay for my parents
for your parents okay I mean parents so
um yeah it's um it's difficult so I
don't know how became like this well
whereas a change began hmm i don't i
really don't know it but it's like this
so i don't have an answer for this i'm
asking it myself describe for us if you
would you were involved in a shocking
incident yeah what happened so I came
for my for my step 4
my university on my way home and I was
in the bus I was sitting in the bath
because I have to travel to a lot of
different districts on evenings East
instead of Berlin and I was there and a
few people came in and taking me and
where were we were very rude and
unfriendly and and my my my I felt I
have I'm not sure if i will survive this
situation and was really really hard for
me and yeah so it was oh yeah one of the
hardest things I have happened so
shopping and it's it's humiliating yeah
for you apart from the immediate pain of
you know being treated in that way and
it's very bad news for me because this
is my city this is the city that I live
in where my kids are growing up with
what is the best way to combat the
problem um now I know it better than
during that time because I was worried
it just was so silently and I didn't
rent to the police I didn't went to any
official organization to talk about it I
didn't went to the media I didn't I did
not made anything during that time now
ever do it in a different way because I
learned I was ever came stronger than
the fact but and but you have to go out
you have to talk about it yes dear about
it I have to answer even now I know but
what I have to do in this situation I
didn't because I just was crying and I
didn't to do anything but normally I
should hopefully I would do stand
hopefully it won't happen again but I
would go up and scream to everybody and
and talk to the bus driver and say stops
us pass and ever do more action but I
wasn't during that time I wasn't
prepared for doing anything ok let's
hope it doesn't happen again hopefully
gospel means good news what's the good
news message from your from your gospel
choir oh so to sing together to sing
together gospel music it's even a
message for them spot cells and so we
are doing a contemporary gospel and a
new gospel and so this is the name of my
quest gospel collective and we are we
had the only female gospel choir and
Germany so the only all-female go so
yeah so and but it's really very
wonderful to sing together and then to
to transport this music to the audience
and down so for me it's the best way to
to bring out their your own feelings too
you're getting very physical if you tell
me that yeah yeah yeah the physical
dimension is actually quite important in
God music it's all about swinging yeah
in a lot of ways could the Germans do it
can they swing so it's difficult sir but
there's a of you who can yes hmm that's
good listen so it's about singing
together it's about being together it's
about the physical thing it's about
swinging it's also about spiritual
energy spiritual fulfillment how
important is that to you very much
because and it's a message there
transport and and and and if you if you
get the feeling that there's there
someone who's holding You who's giving
you peace and m it for me it don't has
to be only God it can be something
different but to have the feeling that
I'm i'm carrying by someone I'm helped
by some and I'm touched by some when I'm
a move by some one it's a good it's a
good message and so that's that's what
I'm thinking about it it is a good
message I'd like to come back to a quote
that I found you do with one of the
local Berlin newspapers you gave an
interview and you said you said I'm
handicapped and black and I'm a woman
and sometimes I find my fate of burden
sometimes I find my fate a blessing tell
me quickly about the burden and tell me
quickly about the blessing yeah so um
it's like I'm and so so I'm blessed by
to have the spirituality trousers
feeling about about life you know to
feel um what is important but it's not
important so I know it and I learned it
very very early behavior when I was very
young so and but it's also a brand
because so the people out that they
don't feel like yours you I'm doing most
of them they don't feel so they're very
happy and they are very well and so for
me it's like it's difficult as well
thank you for sharing all and everything
with a stain great stuff that's all we
have time for on this edition of talking
germany which definitely like a congo
the remarkable life has been great
sharing it with her and I've enjoyed a
company very very much indeed if you
have to come back next week until then
bye bye yes
you